I have to leave Ireland and I have to
leave Scotland where I have great
properties I have to leave early
I don't have to but I choose to will you
attend the trial Mr President
it's a disgrace that it's allowed to
happen it's called false accusations
against a rich guy or in my case against
a famous rich and political person
that's leading the polls by 40 points
and I have to go back for a woman that
made a false accusation about me and I
have a judge who's extremely hostile and
I'm going to go back and I'm going to
confront this with this woman is a
disgrace and it shouldn't be allowed to
happen in our country that's totally
false it was fake she fake
if you wrote it a book a booksha
Democrat
but we have a rough judge
every month you pointed by Bill Clinton
he's a he's a guy that doesn't like me
much he's I guess not allowing the coach
that they wanted to put into evidence
once we said yes put it into evidence
they said oh we don't want to do that
it's a disgrace but I have to do it
that's part of life